hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in letter 33
Seneca is responding to his interlocutor
Lucilius who is asking him for a list or
at least a few Maxim's some sayings that
are nice and short as we say short and
sweet that's right there a maximum when
we use it to describe something and
these are supposed to take the place of
you know thinking deeply about things
they're sort of like what we call sound
bites now or if you've ever seen these
little memes where they'll have a
passage hopefully from the person who
they attribute it to and then usually a
picture of somebody sometimes they
actually get that wrong - they put
somebody who isn't Marcus or Elias but
kinda looks like him in the place people
are constantly mixing up Epictetus and
Epicurus and putting Epicurus is boss
and then they'll be like a little
passage from their works right these are
very popular and they were incredibly
popular in ancient times as well so it
wasn't all that unusual to ask for these
sorts of things you can think all the
way back to for example the Maxim's at
Delphi these nomic Maxim's there's other
things that get brought up constantly if
you look and plate
dialogues people are constantly quoting
this little couplet from Simona tease
the poet or from Homer or Hessian or
whoever so it's not that unusual to
request this sort of thing and as a
matter of fact Luke Helius himself
appears to have been a follower of
Epicurus and we know that the epicurean
circulated around these Maxim's of
Epicurus that were sort of summarizing
his doctrine how do you know that
because that's one of the few things we
still have by Epicurus so sanika is
being asked for this and he says that's
a terrible idea
well you don't need that what we'll talk
about exactly you know why he gives two
main arguments for why it's not a good
thing to be focused on Maxim's but first
he's going to you know say you you want
something more don't you and if we go
deep into it we can see that one of the
criticisms that he has is that these are
in some respects superficial about
midway through he says if you insist I'm
not going to be stingy with you I'll
deal them out by the fistful there's
piles of them lying around one only has
to pick them up there's no need to
collect them they come out not by dribs
and drabs but in a steady flow all
interconnected that's going to be one of
the ideas that's gonna furnish the
criticism that he's going to give
they're all interconnected so he says
I'm sure these do a great deal they they
give a lot Magne to raw beginners Rudy
Bose and listeners from outside of the
school extrinsic oohs I was cool tanta
hos
cult auntie bliss right in the Latin so
he's saying these are useful for a
certain kind of person they're useful
for people who are interested in
stoicism but are at this point outside
of the school they're not actually
studying it in any coherent way or
well-informed way they're also good for
raw beginners because it gives them
something
to start with but what's the implication
here this isn't good for anybody who's
actually going to make any progress so a
tool that can be quite useful at the
beginning if one sticks with it and says
ok now I understand what stoicism is
I've got these little quotes that I can
pop out or I've got them on my phone you
know from some app that's not really
stoicism that's sort of being outside or
being at the total beginner level and
you're not gonna see the benefits of
stoicism from just memorizing a bunch of
quotes that you tried out from time to
time he says that these are like the
Proverbs that sentient EOS given to
children and the Greeks had a word for
these pray us right these are things
that that you could have like ready to
hand and you give them to kids because
kids are actually not smart enough at
least at that point to put everything
together he says that they are what a
child's mind is able to encompass not
yet having room for anything larger so
you know this is a bit of a problem if
this is what grown adults are going to
take stoicism to be because stoicism is
much more than that so he's got a little
bit of criticism here he says it's
shameful when a man who's making
definite progress seizes on flowery bits
or props himself up with a handful of
common places he has memorized at a
certain point you should be leaving
these things behind or at least they
should be contextualized so this leads
us into the second thing and this is a
little bit earlier in the letter one big
issue here is that stoicism is not a
collection of Maxim's or soundbites it
is in fact a complex entire system of
thought that was well worked out over
time we have lost a number of the
ancient stoic texts but they were
available to seneca so he actually has a
better view on that than we do where
he's actually one of the contributors to
it he's he's the one who's helped pass
this on but in his time he's saying
listen you've got all these different
writers you know cruciferous you know
posted onehans he brings up all sorts of
others clay Anthes you you can read
these texts they are available to you
and you don't have to be just working
off of little tiny passages so one
reason why he says that it's in some
respect kind of silly and also hard to
pick out Maxim's is that within the
stoic text the writings evenly contain
important passages there's nothing in
there that's just for you know extra
show or something like that so he begins
at the start by saying Stoics did not
busy themselves with flowery bits of
speech what is noteworthy or what is
noteworthy stands out from the rest you
can be sure the quality is uneven so the
very fact that there aren't any things
that stand out as being above as being
unequal is a sign that the whole is of a
consistent quality and importance so he
goes on and he says here we go
you know we have a number of resources
all equally fine we cannot separate out
just one even if we try wherever you
cast your eyes you will read something
that could have been outstanding here's
the if if the remainder were not equally
good so he's saying I mean you could
read he's not reading Epictetus of
course but we have access to that you
could read Epictetus and you could go
through there and like every single
sentence could be a maxim if you want it
to be because they're all equally good
he's implying that this is probably the
for his own work as well so why are you
picking this passage instead of this
passage and focusing on that they're all
balanced by others that are equally good
so there's a consistent level of quality
then he stresses another thing about
reading and this is what takes us away
from being beginners or being people
outside of the system who don't really
understand it except through little you
know short passages that are not totally
representative he says that the subject
matters treated along the lines that are
proper to it and an intellectual product
is devised from with from which nothing
can be removed without a collapse right
says when you're reading works of great
people you must read them as holes come
to grips with them as holes tota is the
word that he's using there the totality
of it you need to grapple with them is
another way to say it instead of just
you know trying to find yourself you
know best hits list or you know one of
these books that's got a few you know
passages here and they're all put
together you don't really want that you
want to read the actual texts and
understand them and understand the mind
of the author so that then you can you
know fully grasp what the philosophy
entails and this is something that you
can apply not just the stoicism but to
philosophy in general even aphoristic
philosophers like Nietzsche
you don't understand Nietzsche if all
you do is say to yourself over and over
again what doesn't kill me makes me
stronger I mean that's even out of
context because Nietzsche says the
military mind that which does not kill
me makes me stronger he's not saying
this is a you know maxim that holds for
everybody or anything like that right so
we need context we need things to be the
context means to be woven together text
them in Latin right and so if you don't
read the thing where all these passages
are indeed woven
together in a hole you're missing out on
a lot of what even the isolated passage
itself means so that's that's one big
argument that he's making another quite
interesting one is that stoicism is a
lived-in practice philosophy he says you
know that we have all these great
thinkers you know who should we
attribute our you know little texts to
to Zeno to clan thiis to cruciferous to
posted Onias to pin to mate to pen a
theist we are not under a monarch each
of us have certs his own freedom right
and a little bit later after he's talked
about isn't it kind of shameful to be
like constantly quoting people and not
really have any thoughts of your own he
says let this person stand on his own
feet let him say these things for
himself not recall what he's memorized
for shame that an old person or one
nearly old should get his wisdom from a
textbook this is what Xena said what do
you actually say clan 'they said this
well what do you say how long will you
march under another's command take
charge say something memorable on your
own account bring forth something from
your own store so this is kind of a a
measure of whether you're actually
understanding stoicism that you don't
just remain with all these you know
little isolated sayings but that you
actually produce your own work and it
might not necessarily be writing or
speaking it might just be how you
actually live it out but you're not
going to be living it out just according
to a code book with a bunch of you know
short sayings and and that would include
epictetus is enchiridion written much
later of course than Seneca but that
would not be enough to go on
so stoicism means that we should also be
as as Seneca Staz authors through action
coming up with our own ways of
understanding these things so he says I
feel all those people who are never
authors but always interpreters
concealing themselves in the shadow of
another have nothing Noble in them
they've never dared to put into action
they've been so long in learning they've
trained their memories on other people's
words but remembering is one thing
knowing is another remembering is
keeping track of something that you
committed he says to to memory
knowing is making those things your own
not having to depend on a model or keep
looking to your teacher for instructions
it doesn't mean that you're gonna like
make it all up as you go along obviously
it is still interpretation but its
interpretation that is creative and
productive and that is also faithful to
the teachings by bringing them into new
context so this is what Seneca has to
tell his friend he's happy to give him
Maxim's but he doesn't want him to rely
on them I think this is advice that is
just as relevant in the present about
stoicism and so many other philosophies
as it was in Senecas time particularly
in our internet age where people love
having short passages and thinking that
thereby they understand a philosophy
you